the jurgen experience
wasn't that ric flair what's that nwa it
was ric flair and then they wanted him
to go www
yeah picture everybody was too late
that's right
dude i have ric flair t-shirts now you
should rick flair is a bad [ __ ]
i'm trying to get him on my show
yeah you should have him on here i would
love to have him on here rick if you're
you're out there sir open invitation
dude
but when i'm interested you've seen that
video of uh the football players
in the green room yes or in the locker
room yes repeating it and then
in between rick the nature boy flair
saying it back
no i haven't seen that yeah i just
didn't know please bring that up see if
you can find it
it's uh i forget the team that was doing
it but they were yelling
out his slogan and in between limousine
riding yeah
tuxedo and i'm having a hard time
keeping these gators down here it is
here it is
give it to me from the beginning wrong
[Applause]
limousine ride whoa that's fine
sir
now they did this and then they spliced
it in with ric flair see if you can find
that
it's them saying one line and then ric
flair saying the second line and then
going back to that
i'm having a hard time holding these
alley get us down yeah dude it's [ __ ]
amazing
i don't think that's it see there's a
video out there
someone has it dude i've never someone
sent it to jamie on twitter
i've never been more moved by a
documentary than my watches
this is it
just stealing wheeling dealing
limousines right
[Music]
[Laughter]
someone like a catchphrase like
someone's saying something that just
that just gives you goosebumps and makes
you fired up or make you start [ __ ]
clapping dude
dude to this day if you say ric flair on
stage and hold the microphone out the
whole audience will go
even australia while matthews was like
balls deep
with that guy gouging his eyes out you
heard whoo
yeah dude everybody all over the world
all over the world but
it's like an amazing weird occurrence
that happens every now and then where a
guy just
nails something and becomes a part of
pop culture forever but think about it
floyd connor they're all ripping off
from him that's where they got it
remember he was way before
all of them well
muhammad ali was talking [ __ ] like that
in the 1960s not like that though right
not like boasting about what his riches
and like
you know what i'm saying oh my god that
level did you ever
joke dude muhammad ali would write poems
i know poems but not about money and
splurging and limousines and [ __ ] and
alligators
maybe not about [ __ ] but you know how
great he was
it's different though he talked about
how great he was he's finishing around
stuff like that i've seen that
i'm saying as far as like boasting and
and that almost that that low
level um where you rags the riches right
you know what i'm saying
like maybe he did i don't know but i
know he would be little people
to no end for sure he said about jimmy
terrell he said
jimmy turell if he dreams he beats me
better wake up and apologize
like he was he would say [ __ ] who he
fought
you said that whoever he's fighting i
thought it was the frasier we said for
you in dreams about being
right i don't think it was but i mean
there were so many of those [ __ ]
interviews where he talked so much crazy
[ __ ] you talk [ __ ] but i'm telling you
give me something
he must fall in five rounds but if you
talk about me i'll cut it three
i'll never fight another fella as tough
as dog jones not even that big ugly bear
son and listen
is he your next fight well after i
annihilate this henry cooper i want that
bear
and what's gonna happen what's gonna
happen he might be great but he'll fall
in 8.
i'm the prettiest sight in the ring
today that's my label
[Music]
he was a smart guy man he talked crazy
super smart
i'm too fast but it was always about his
skills it wasn't like i have this much
money i have a limo i have a rolex
where like floyd and like rick yeah took
that to another level
that's true right he took the i'm a rich
guy thing to a new level
and i bragged about his riches because
he was a heel so he's like i got money i
got [ __ ] i got
gators for coats what's up i'm having a
hard time
holding these alligators down
you